today no new car hits the show room
without being rammed into walls barriers
and other automobiles to make sure
you're safe in your vehicle
initially crash test sites focused on
what happened inside the car the drivers
and passengers aren't the only victims
of crashes
[Applause]
pedestrians are often involved in
serious accidents and they don't come
with airbags but how do you make cars
safer for people walking down the street
you do pedestrian crash testing its
research so cutting-edge that there are
only a handful of testing facilities in
the world here at Honda Rd Americas in
Raymond Ohio these guys have been
studying pedestrian collisions for five
years it's the major focus of their
crash test site
the man in charge of the pedestrian
crash test is Honda's automotive safety
testing specialist Brad Arne
Brad and his team work with a highly
specialized dummy designed just for
Honda
they spent a million dollars developing
the prototype each polar - costs
$300,000 and only three exist in the
world the polar - dummy actually has a
need that that is a has four ligaments
in it just like a human knee it has a
tibia that's consumable that's
replaceable in between tests if it is to
break the ribs actually use a different
type of sensor than their normal dummy
the arm has better range of motion it's
just more anthropomorphic ly correct
than an actual dummy that you'd use in a
frontal collision the polar - maybe the
most evolved crash-test dummy in history
and Brad and his team are getting ready
to run theirs over with a big SUV today
their concern is preventing you from
being killed by head injuries they're
focusing on where the bumper is placed
and the shape of the hood
so what's going to happen as the Acura
MDX is going to start down about 90
meters down the tunnel we'll hook it up
to the cable and get the cable in the
car going up to 40 kilometers an hour
and it'll hit this trigger on the floor
releasing the magnet one meter from
impact the car will hit the trigger
everything is calculated so the dummy
will be standing still at the moment of
impact the dummy does not have any time
to actually come down or move from the
time that dummy is released to the
impact is about 30 milliseconds that's
30 thousandths of a second it's that
quick the exact position of the dummy at
the time of impact is crucial the goal
is to get him in the same position each
time so our results are repeatable so
that we can make effective
countermeasures based on repeatability
cameras already
festering's ready lights are a alright
give me a countdown
[Music]
you